to do the pre-sequel we were trying to
look for characters that could show up
and do really cool stuff but also had a
context these this thing beforehand so
what we did was we looked at the
characters we're actually around
handsome jack at the time said or any of
these characters that we'd like to turn
into something and these characters
worth exploring and so what we landed on
we got Misha to La Brea
we've got Athena we've got Wilhelm and
of course claptrap there's two female
characters there's one male character
and there's a robot it's about
reflecting people as they are in the
world that's where on earth our bands
and people as they're right initially
when we built this universe said it's
going to be diverse it's going to be
interesting and it's going to be
culturally diverse because culture is
something we door
I got some feedback from Zach on the
sugar s and how I'm gonna have the
rapids attack the players so I'm going
to try out a couple of suggestions that
he made including giving them a
lightning Chetta it could be funny so
I'm going to try it
well you become one of the vault hunters
one of the heroes that's sort of working
with handsome jack during his rise to
power
and his closest countenance it was very
clear and water lines to where we'll
home and nisha now Wilhelm we know what
he came to becoming board lands to
something that's really unique about him
is York's officially changing him you're
unlocking Rabbani calms your political
legs in the pre-sequel he starts out
fully human and as you build out a skill
tree he like slowly becomes more
cybernetic and also he has is to support
drones which is his special ability one
of them will go out and attack and then
the other one what's the King behind and
recharge Wilhelm shields this is cool
and like you just you feel like I'm just
cool and then we've got Misha
who's the gunslingers and she's like
it's a Wild West everybody love Nisha
she was this character that we all
regret killing off spoiler yeah so when
you meet Nisha
she is a bandit that kills other bandits
she just worse than handsome jack in
many ways like she just enjoys
strangling puppies she's actually just
about the most evil character in the
entirety of the portal and universe and
that's kind of fun I know people have
been asking does Nisha have the whiffle
yes she has the width and it's a long
range melee attack so Anitra's action
skills called showdown and it allows for
to automatically aim at enemies it gives
her a bunch of buffs to a bunch of
different things and then if you iron
sight and then quickly switch targets
you get that put each move feeling of
like a banner bandage sort of deceiving
your gun really quickly it's a thing
you're gonna use in every single combat
you get into to get the snack useful so
what you can see here is any but during
the action skill any guy you shoot the
bolts ricochet and hit multiple guys
there's some force all right there's
more guys here's be some action story
you have this one alright do it okay
that is cool guys even the Ricochet
going on oh that's good that tore clean
did not survive that at all
Athena is a character from the general
Knoxx DLC from Borderlands 1 the third
DLC she was just a cool NPC that fought
alongside you and help you take down a
bunch of bad guys and we really wanted
to explore her story and her difficulty
and balance between good and evil
because she's sort of an assassin trying
to find a way atlas is completely gone
she is out of money she's out of food
she needs to take any job she came to
get by we also been talking about having
a character with a shield three years
but they're not as much fun to play in a
video game because you're walking behind
this shield moving really slow we wanted
someone who was fast and active and
energetic and got to the paddle so
thenis action skill is the kinetic ask
his shield and it basically works where
she puts it in front of her body and any
incoming damage that happens to the
shield basically charges out their power
and you build that skill up we can get
to the point where you can take out
three or four or five of those enemies
we have that with that shield down
that's just really cool to play with
Athena's a badass I just feel like an
awesome like ass-kicking superhero when
I play Athena
aw snap
mr. Balaji do they call for the fourth
character
I could tell many stories but the truth
is Randy Pitchford the president's
company who really wanted to play this
claptrap claptrap is a wild character
you know we know claptrap he's been in
the series forever and I chef is a
Hyperion robot so there's a really
interesting set of narrative
circumstances that allow him to actually
be on Hanson Jack's team and that time
between 100 and 102 the idea is great
like hey wouldn't it be interesting to
finally play as claptrap but what does
that actually mean cop traps a little
bit of here a little bit in Compton
there's a little bit of unpredictable
and he's kind of an idiot lovable idiot
but he's kind of an idiot
I think Hyperion actually labeled it as
malware at some point his action skill
is is lunacy if you don't want to be
claptrap you definitely want him on your
team because when claptrap uses his
actions feel it affects everybody in the
game and oftentimes for good but
sometimes just weird stuff happens just
you fall stuff in the hole gameplay
changes people are kind of telling the
story off their experience of playing it
as claptrap and everyone's gonna have a
completely different story to tell
orleans is all about building and what's
happened before so to build a stronger
product next time a lot of the things
that were still kind of lingering that
just needed to get out of this after
we'd finished borderlands 2 we're able
to get into borderlands the pre-sequel
and weapons it was like okay well what
gun fantasy are we not hitting because
we have the Western fantasy with Jacobs
we have the you know American action
movie star with tor we want to make
people feel like they're having a fresh
experience you know it's a big game you
get your money's worth when you play a
borderland skin and that is a thrill